Hello
stitches,
you know,
it's a process.
We're,
we're all a part of this process.
We,
you and I have both
seen each other evolve.
We just don't really realize it as
much because we evolve together.
Right.
But if we went back in time 10 years
ago to when we met and then like when we
meet,
we'll use it.
It was about 10 years ago.
A little over that I think.
Really?
Yeah.
I might've been like 2001
or something like that.
What's it like even before that dude?
Yeah.
I knew you not allowed Joe.
I bet.
I bet you don't remember this.
I remember the first time that you really,
yes,
I was,
this was when I was,
uh,
Cory's assistant at the
comedy store and we,
I was sitting next to you.
Um,
and you are,
I think you had,
this was right around when you just
started smoking weed or you'd become,
you are more,
you are kind of a marijuana starting
to become a marijuana advocate at this
time.
But it wasn't,
this is what's called my annoying phase.
No,
but it was really funny.
It.
Yeah,
it was an annoying thing.
It was really funny
cause I was sitting man.
No I was sitting next to you
and I at the time I had been,
I got,
I went through this being
a marijuana advocate phase,
like you know a few,
a few years before.
But remember sitting nice and you were
talking about weed and as a joke cause I
didn't know you that well.
He didn't know me and as a dumb joke I
was like man we should be illegal and you
shot me this fucking look man you are,
you are like sure
make an accident.
As you thought how it you gotta
put some fake dress up on his head.
He was all Gary Oldman.
Him Mom,
you seem to know.
I said it should be okay.
You Eagle and you seem so pissed.
And then Cory like was like to shut up,
shut up.
Don't say anything because you,
we didn't know each other and I could
have seem like a real asshole at the time.
But then,
then I don't remember that at all.
I know.
I think you might just
be a little paranoid.
I think he tuned me out.
I probably would.
I don't think I would cut it like,
like,
like got angry with you
and you don't get angry.
I pride flooring dare you?
Yeah.
Well I was making it
one of two things.
Either you were trying to make a joke,
which would be not funny and I would
be bored with it or I'd be like,
what an asshole.
Oh,
just,
I think it was the fall.
It was the former.
And then after that we started talking
on the phone and we start having
conversations
this on the phone we've been at Duncan
and I used to have these fucking 45
minute phone calls where a
call him up cause Dunkin was,
uh,
the dude who like you'd say,
Hey,
I can work a Tuesday through
Thursday of this week and go,
okay,
cool.
And then he would,
you know,
they'd get together and create a schedule.
You'd call it Dunkin would,
uh,
get your avail.
So me and Dunkin just
started talking on the phone.
I don't know what started it off.
We'd have these crazy ass
45 minute fucking while he's working at
the comedy store and every now and be
like,
oh,
hold on a second dude,
sorry.
He put me on hold and have to
answer some other phone call.
And so got to lay in your bed with
your little swatch phone baked as fuck.
Donald was high on the job.
Every god Damn Day work there,
right?
There's all kinds of,
yeah,
it's,
it sucks man.
People,
the brain is an organ
and it malfunctions and,
and sometimes you go nuts and that's,
and you get stigmatized for it,
which really sucks because if you like,
because that just adds to the problem.
Like if you,
you know,
you see somebody in a
cast and you're like,
oh,
what happened to your arm?
And they'll tell you,
oh,
you know,
whatever.
I fell down.
But you,
you talked to someone who's
been hospitalized for a
few weeks and they tell you
I had to go to the hospital.
I had a nervous breakdown.
I went crazy shit.
My pants through my dog through a window.
You're like,
you're like,
you know you,
you'll want,
you want to be compassionate,
but there's some part of you that's like,
oh,
now this is a crazy person.
It's like it's just something happened.
The operating system temporarily crashed
and quite often I think that could be a
very good thing.
I think that having your,
your personality or your ego or crash
can often mean that you were trying to be
somebody that you aren't and some
people invest so much energy,
so much energy into trying to find me.
Yeah.
They just want to be some thing.
You know,
they,
they it,
since there were a kid there,
mother was telling them,
you should be like this and then they
try to be like this and they hold up this
thing.
They're always working to hold up this
giant tail feather in their arms start
shaking and that they can't hold it up
and that's when they have like anger
outbursts are suddenly like
their friends are like you.
You turned into someone
that I've never met.
I don't even know who that is.
It's like,
no,
that is,
you met them,
you met underneath the tail feather,
the seeding,
see anger and disappointment and sadness.
They that you met,
that thing that they're,
they're trying to avoid by
looking up at this mask.
They're holding up to the world,
but that fucking saving,
see of disappointment,
anger and horror and sadness.
That's where it's at,
man.
You got to go into that thing and it's,
for some people,
the only way they can go into that is
by having a full scale nervous breakdown
because then they can have
permission to dive into that,
into that awful vortex of darkness because
underneath that vortex of darkness is
paradise.
Underneath that,
that's love and happiness and joy and
connection and tranquility and all that
stuff and everyone's thinks that the
way to get to that point is by avoiding
this awful black forest that
surrounds the garden of Eden,
which is inside everybody.
It's inside everybody.
It's there,
it's there and it doesn't matter.
You know you can work out and that
will definitely give you a temporarily
temporary good feeling,
but until you address the internal
structures that you haven't acknowledged,
you're always going to go back to that
place where you find yourself morose and
depressed and angry,
and you don't know why.
You always go back to that place until
you sit with the sadness inside of you.
You have to do that.
What you're describing is
coming out of the closet.
Yeah.
For a lot of people,
that is what it is,
man.
It's coming out of the closet
and there's a lot of closets,
man.
There's not just the gay closet,
right?
There's all kinds of closet.
There's the artists closet.
Some people are fucking accountants.
They're wearing suits and their ties on
tight and they're fucking like organized
and disciplined,
but inside they're probably painters.
They probably want it fucking paint.
They want to paint day
mountains down at the beach.
That's what they really are,
but their daddy or their mommy wanted
them to be a good little businessman,
so they became this thing that's
the opposite of what they are.
This is the verse in the Bhagavad Gita.
God,
forgive me cause I've quoted
it way too many times,
but it's,
it's better to be an honest street
sweeper than a dishonest king.
It's better to be a happy guy brushing
fucking leafs up the street than it is to
be some zillionaire who inside
is dying or numb or miserable,
mostly numb,
numbs the word.
Most people are just not.
As long as these people
can quantify on paper,
I still have a x million dollar home.
My car still cost x thousand
dollars this suit is an ex suit.
I am still ahead.
I am not going to abandon
all of these things.
As long as they don't see
through the bullshit of the game.
They think they're winning.
They have to file.
It's almost like you have
to fall to to really,
that's what you got to appreciate those
moments when it all falls apart on you
because that means you've got
an opportunity to try it again.
This is,
let's take a new fresh perspective.
This is the cool thing that
at this retreat I went to
this Guy Jack Cornfield's
out,
which I really loved.
[inaudible] great name by the way.
Yeah.
With a k,
not a c,
Jack Kornfield,
mortal Kombat,
k Jack Cornfield.
But he,
uh,
he's really cool man.
But he was cool.
He's a cat,
like the cigarette corny.
Now this guy was awesome and he was one
of the things he talked about his in
some religious tradition,
how they like hold the scriptures a
rabbi like had his students hold the
scriptures over their heart and uh,
when they were memorizing
them and they would say,
why do we do this?
And he said,
so that when your heartbreaks,
they'll fall in.
And it's a beautiful idea,
which is that heartbreak is
actually your ego cracking.
And the moment that cracks,
you're in the experience of truth.
And when you're in the
experience of truth,
that's when you can
really become who you are.
But,
but to get to who you are,
it's like when you know,
when a bone heals the wrong way,
like that's what a lot of
people's entire personality is.
It's like a bone that grew the wrong
way and that needs a fucking a snap,
a crack,
you know,
and we,
you get that through sex,
you need that,
that initial fucking thing.
And it's a beautiful analogy and it hurts.
It hurts.
But we're paying avoiding creatures.
So we think that,
so we're always running
away from this pain.
But the problem is as we're
running away from pain,
we're still exactly in pain.
It's basically like being on
fire and running away from water.
You're just running away
from the water because you,
for some,
I don't know,
that's a stupid analogy
actually for doing great.
Up until that you had
a lot of great points.
What it's true,
you know,
there's the monster in the
dark and the faster you run,
the more likely you are to
run into something that's
actually going to hurt you
as opposed to turning around and saying,
Oh fuck,
there is no monster.
No Monster.
No.
But you never get to know that
until you stop and turn around.
You know?
And in some cases people don't
have the discipline or the,
the assistance or the balls to stop.
And turn around so they have to
trip over something and then there's
like,
oh,
there's the classic story
of someone hiding a secret
and going completely out of
control because of the
pressure of hiding that.
Right.
Like that's the Ted Haggerty who's the
secretly gay guy who's preaching against
gay people.
Ted Haggard in Colorado was
snorting meth off his gay lovers.
Yeah.
We was just going so far the other way.
He just so off the rails crazy himself.
He's being himself.
He was a guy who likes
to snort math off of Cox,
who I still a little math and he likes to,
well,
there's a few Cox,
but I would say he wasn't being himself.
What I would say is that his,
his behavior was so extreme because he
was seeking balance between that and the
other bull shit in his life.
Whereas if he weren't living that,
he'd be right in the middle.
Right?
Yeah.
Well to give it to get to the middle.
You know,
the way to get to the middle weirdly
is whatever the behavior is that you're
doing that you're so horrified
about and terrified of sometimes.
They're really weird ideas.
This is like something that
I liked that Ron doss has,
which is like if you don't
feel like meditating,
don't meditate.
Don't force it.
Don't impose this on yourself.
Keep doing the thing you're doing
that's upsetting you so much.
Have the balls to keep doing the
fucking thing that you're doing.
Keep doing it.
If society is going to tell you,
don't be like this.
Stop being like this.
You have to change.
That's what your parents always say.
The idea is like no,
sink into what you are right now.
Just be that thing.
Stop resisting exactly where you are
right now is perfect and that's a hard
truth to grasp.
I will take,
I would take 5,000 Casey
Anthony's over one.
Nancy grace any day of the week.
Nancy grace is a fucking foul.
Necrophiles I think she is so much
more disgusting than some strippers kid
gotten to her ecstasy
or whatever happened.
It's like,
who?
Who like,
yeah,
a dumb girls kiss.
She left the kid in the
backseat of the car,
fell on the Kiddie pool cause
she's negligent or whatever.
It's like sad and terrible.
But Nancy grace get like clearly
getting off on the whole situation.
I hate those,
uh,
those tabloid death.
Hags like grace.
I,
there's some other woman I saw too
is like on the view and she was like,
we just got the verdict,
the Casey Anthony Verdict.
I'm gonna need your help here.
She said,
Oh God,
you,
no,
it's just disgusting.
You're weeping because this
one mother got off the hook.
Meanwhile,
every year in Afghanistan and Iraq,
the UN is dropping bombs on neighborhoods.
Kids are getting blown to smithereens.
Kids are getting transformed
into hamburger meat on a
daily basis and the Middle
East,
because of our fucked up drones that
keep accidentally bombing weddings and
neighborhoods and these murder,
these death hags are freaking
out over one dead child.
I mean,
it's sad.
It's very sad.
That cake Caylee Anthony died.
I mean,
I think that's terribly sad.
But when you hear Nancy
grace being like Kylie,
Anthony's bleached bones were found but
cable or pyre up writer and all those
honor.
Nick was one fabric,
one bit of her taste shirt.
It's like there's a grow,
there's a disgusting,
there's something perverse behind it.
Thank you.
Sorry about that
dude.
You don't have to.
I'm a big Fan Bashing Nancy grace.
What a pig.
There's something gross about when I,
whenever I see someone who's angry and
they're fat like that and I'm like,
maybe you need to go on a diet and
you won't be so fucking angry dog.
The bounty.
I see someone with his
big jowls in this big,
you know I've,
I'm like exercise,
eat right.
Take some yoga classes.
You'll approach this all
totally different somewhere.
The devil is dancing to not the top.
Mom's off the hook.
Tiger Woods.
That's a another one.
She went after.
She went off to tiger woods for like,
you guys need to stop watching me.
So much slides.
Brilliant.
I think him and Nancy Grace are going
to burn and a specific part of whatever
hell there may be my baby that
gets eaten by Florida for it.
It will turn into a
mouth and eat that baby.
I think he's hoping the swamps will open
up and you'll see teeth come out of the
ground.
Snatch up the child.
Man,
I would love to dead babies.
It wasn't looking for Laura De,
you know,
it'd be so fun.
This is a weird thought that
I've had to wait a minute.
You yeah,
I know.
Get Out.
But if Nancy grace as a full grown
thing is disgusting and foul,
but if you could shrink Nancy grace down
and have like a pocket Nancy grace that
lived in a little aquarium,
some little judgemental death con
that you hadn't been in an aquarium.
That was just
a little show to the right thing.
Tiger Woods,
Charles,
those girls that he loved them.
We'll go to the next caller.
Is it a dead baby in Florida?
It is the semen stains on the mattress.
Can we zoom in on those?
Let's get dog the bounty hunter and here
to dirty nails scratching your clit,
going Pumpkin,
Siemens,
Simon.
That's her mantra.
When she walks,
she chant Simon steins and Nancy grace
holds the world record for the longest
squirt ever by a female vagina kind of
squirt like 18 feet.
Yeah,
I think that that sport happened,
did not score.
It happened when she saw Jon
Benet Ramsey death picture.
And,
uh,
I've gotten more than one email from
really dumb people think that because I am
playing at the Masonic Auditorium,
it just proves that I am
a new world order shill.
You're,
you're an reptile dude.
You follow why bringer.
Lord Lucifer,
I am a part of the masonic,
uh,
what do they call themselves?
Brotherhood.
They're a fraternity and fraternity
part of the Masonic fraternity.
And uh,
I mean with the new world order,
because I'm planning at
the Nob Hill Masonic it,
you know what a Mason told me once he
said that what it's all about is that math
or geometry is the first
language of the universe.
It's like the first language of God.
And so like,
they're super into sacred geometry.
Like,
that's a big thing.
And like the whole thing is based
on building the Temple of Solomon,
which is where you,
how's the Ark of the covenant?
You know,
it's all symbolic of course.
But the new temple of Solomon that
they're trying to build according to the
conspiracy theorists is
society like this is it.
Like society is the New Temple of Solomon.
And part of that was getting the United
States revolution to happen because they
help fund that and also fucking DC,
the street layout of DC is all masonic
symbols and that goddamn obelisks popping
up out of the middle of fucking DC,
that weird thing.
And it's all over our fucking money.
So yeah,
Joe,
we are worried about you.
There is something going
on behind the scenes,
right?
I mean it's,
it's clear if you look at the design
of Washington DC and folks who should
really should look this up online,
cause it's not something that,
it's irrefutable.
The Grid,
the grid,
the way they've lined up the streets,
the way they put the
buildings and everything.
I mean it literally is masonic symbols.
It is.
And it's all of our fucking money to,
yeah.
Yeah.
What's up with that
fucking all seeing eye,
just an eye on top of a
pyramid that makes sense.
The United States and its
long love affair with Egypt.
Think how the Egyptians
help form our constitution.
Right.
No one thinks about that shit.
That's what's so fun about the call.
You know,
cause the word a call itself means hidden,
but it's like hidden in plain view
because this shit's in front of everybody.
Like all the people who deny conspiracy
theories and stuff in their wallet or
Fucking rectangles covered in
Egyptian occult symbology did.
They don't even think about,
for folks who don't know the,
what the symbols are in Washington DC,
the way it's set up is
one of them is a Lucifer,
uh,
uptight upside down Pentagram.
Sure.
I mean,
so the horns stick up in the air.
I mean there's,
that's,
that's there.
I mean they did design this.
They really did design
the streets like this.
And the other one is,
um,
like that masonic symbol that
looks like a measuring device.
Yeah.
That,
that means a lot.
But yeah,
that's why,
that's why they liked that,
because they're trying,
what they're trying to do is to
sort of articulate the primary,
um,
the,
the very first way that the universe form,
which is through geometry or through
like a cascade of like specific physical
laws that are based on math.
It's super fucking cool,
man.
I mean,
it's what masons are.
Well,
that's what amazing told me at a wedding.
I don't know.
He's drunk too.
Yeah.
I met a drunk mason at a,
at a show at the laugh factory in Houston.
It was showing me his mason ids and shit.
And I'm like,
what the fuck is being a mason?
What do you,
what do you guys do?
It's like,
Oh man,
it's just secret society.
You know,
hung out together.
Yeah.
Hang out together.
We had two rituals where you
come out of a fucking coffin.
I know that happens.
Okay.
But how much power do you
really think they have?
We'll try to use,
is there really anything to what
they're doing or is like being a mason?
Just fun?
Uh,
I an elk's lodge ever.
There's bunches,
there's many different levels of the
thing and I imagine that a lot of Masons,
uh,
are probably in politics and when you're,
when you're in a fraternity
and you're in politics,
you're probably going to pay deference
to other people in your fraternity when
it comes to working together to make
laws happen or whatever you're up to.
So I though a lot of people say
it's a waning population that,
that the masons are kind of like dying
out because fewer young people are
signing up because they don't recruit.
So to become a mason
you have to ask a mason,
so you'd have to go to the
masonic lodge and be like,
I want to become a Freemason.
And then they do like background
checks on you and become masons.
Yes,
let's do it.
I think it'd be a blast.
What do you think is
good about being a mason?
I think ceremony is people
that's right now in front of
Peter.
It's fucking shit.
He's a fucking new world order.
Shields.
Where's the Alex Jones hotline number?
I need to call him.
Right.
Joe Rogan has publicly admitted
on his show that he is amazing.
He has Duncan Trussell on talks about
how wonderful it is to be amazing and
spreading propaganda.
And this information about
Mason's being about geometry,
they're about control or
about taking your soul,
ladies and gentlemen,
not going to stand for,
well man,
I don't know.
You know,
I who knows.
I think uh,
ceremony is a,
as something that is missing from a lot
of people's lives in our culture because
it's so goddamn weird.
And I was like,
someone wants to get married.
Yeah,
yeah,
I guess so.
Yeah.
If someone wants to get mad,
well that is that definitely,
that is definitely a ceremony.
But like,
you know,
there's a lot of other ceremonies
to that aren't quite so,
uh,
based on like on stupid shit.
But I mean there,
but they are like,
there's their,
their psychedelic man.
And like I read this somewhere,
I don't remember who said it,
but it was uh,
an interesting point,
which is that a rock show is a ceremony
and the sense that you're going to this
to watch people on stage crew like doing
like songs which are a kind of chant
that everyone already knows and you're
taking psychedelics to go enjoy this
thick.
So it's like that,
you know,
that Youngian idea that like there's
just certain basic things that tend to
repeat through all different cultures.
And the way it's repeated in
our culture is more through,
I'm going to go see a rock show and
dress in a certain way and take a
psychedelic and trip out and have a kind
of transcendent experience that comes
through the music.
But it used to be like,
there's more formal versions of that idea,
which is like you take a psychedelic
and then you do a series of like
intonations or whatever the fuck it is
depending on what religion or cult you're
in.
And that creates a kind of
transcendent connective experience,
which I think is fucking awesome.
And it's fun to just watch regardless of
whether or not you believe in what that
red religion or ritual
is trying to invoke.
It's just cool to watch that
form of dance and movement happen
that the horrible idea,
especially horrible to bring it up to
anybody who's had poor fortune in this
life is to somehow or another
connected with past lives.
You know,
and you've ever heard
someone say that like,
Oh,
you must've been a real
fuck had in his past life.
And it's like,
wow,
like what are you really?
Are you sure?
You sure could it just not be a roll of
the dice and maybe part of your Karma is
recognizing that?
I think that,
yeah,
that's why I like the uh,
you know,
uh,
Buddha.
Yeah,
I like him.
Like Buddha said,
don't well,
don't think about the afterlife so much.
I think even Christ said,
I am the god of the living,
not the god of the dead.
The idea being the voice.
I am the god of the living.
It's a good,
I think real spiritual masters always
tend to try to bring people back into the
present moment because it's like,
yeah,
you know what the present
moment is everything.
I know when Shit goes wrong in my life,
I know why it went wrong.
I don't have to go back to when I was
a fryer and the 18 hundreds and like
fisted a fucking,
you know none.
I know that if shit's
going wrong right now,
generally it's like,
cause I'm fucking up now.
It's good for,
and people can get lost.
People can start blaming their,
their Karma,
uh,
or where they're at
right now in past lives.
And it puts him in this place of stupid
hopelessness and they don't do the
things they need to do right
now to get to a better place.
Praise Jesus.
Praise the Lord.
Because I,
his name's so many fucking say,
hey,
his name,
how many
simple things you could do,
man,
all you got.
Here's what you have to do.
This is my new theory.
Identify the vampire in your life.
Find the vampire,
identify the parasite.
It doesn't have to be that
you have parasites in life.
It is possible that you could've gotten
lucky and there's no parasites and you
get off groovy.
Sure.
No,
I'm not saying everyone's got one,
but if you got one,
if you're walking around with
those fucking vampire blues,
you've got the fucking
heavy heart and you'd,
and you can't feel happy and you feel bad,
there may be an action that you need
to take that you're afraid take.
That's the vampire and you've
got to fucking not even a person.
Oh No,
I mean it's a situation,
a,
yeah,
it's a vampire in your life.
Find the life sucking situation
that you're afraid to kill.
And the reason I say vampires because
vampire is only go or they're invited.
And generally the
situation that you're in,
you invited it in,
you invited this thing into your life
and now it's sucking your life energy in
your blood and your happiness away,
don't it?
And it's in a lot of times
you'll try to believe,
you'll try to convince yourself
that this thing is not a vampire,
but in your heart,
you know you're a servant.
To a fucking blood sucker.
You are.
Ren felt.
This thing is like sucking
your life as it's way.
Sometimes it's doing it with a trade.
Quite often there'll be a bad trade.
You'll be,
you know,
whatever the situation
you're in and you'll,
you'll,
it'll be,
you'll feel like you're in the situation.
You know,
it's worth it.
It's kind of bad,
but it's totally worth it.
This happens with jobs quite often,
you know,
or you're like,
well,
you know,
but it's good enough.
That's the vampire.
You got to take a fucking stake and drive
it into its art to how do you kill a
vampire?
Two ways.
Direct Action.
You don't kill a vampire by
like making up with a vampire.
You don't kill the vampire by like having
a sit down and talk with a vampire.
You're not going to be able to like,
uh,
you know,
make friends with the vampire.
There's two ways to kill a vampire.
One,
you fucking,
you know,
uh,
put a stake in its heart.
The other one is light,
sunlight,
truth,
light that it's the greatest
metaphor of all time.
You shine the light of
truth onto the situation,
fearlessly analyze it and
then you'll destroy it.
You know?
Because if you really allow
yourself a few can act,
you got to add.
The real problem with people
is not recognizing the enemy.
It's acting on that enemy.
That's the real problem.
And that enemy being,
you know,
personal,
your personal demons,
your,
your personal jihad,
that's a personal issue.
You got to fight the beast and it's,
and you know what I mean?
It's like everybody's beast is different.
Chapter two of the Bhagavad Gita,
arginase dejection arginine has
drawn between these two forces.
He does not want to fight.
He drops his bow and God says to him,
you've got rise to the fight.
Fight.
You're a warrior.
This is what you're here for.
Fight,
fight.
It's,
it's better to die.
It's better to die in a righteous battle.
Then goes skulking off into the
fucking woods and be a beggar.
It's better to fucking do what you do on
your award or you got to fucking do it,
man.
It fucking sucks.
When when you're drunk and you want to
throw up and you try to not make yourself
throw up,
just throw up.
You'll feel better.
You'll feel better in the end.
When you're puking it's going to suck
because you're helpless and you can't
breathe.
Go through it,
man.
Fucking jab a fucking knife into the fuck.
Not Literally of course,
but yeah,
you got to act and you got to make the
big fucking decisions sometimes and it's
scary.
If it wasn't scary,
it wouldn't be worth anything.
Yeah.
For some people it's almost like
they don't know how to start the,
they know that there's actions
that need to take in their life,
but they're paralyzed
trying to think about it,
trying to figure out how to start and
they can never gather up the courage to
get away.
It's like,
what's not.
A lot of people stay in
abusive relationships.
They don't,
they don't have the courage to leave.
Exactly.
Cause it's scary and it in
it and it seems like it,
you know,
there's so many things that people
will like w ideas people will create.
They'll keep you trapped.
And whenever prisoner,
it's very similar to um,
and not,
I mean,
what you're talking about in the
UFC with these fucking fighters,
this is a visual representation of
what anyone can do in their life.
But you mean you're not getting,
maybe not all of us are going to get
obviously be worldclass fighters.
They get in a ring in front of the entire
planet and fucking knock someone out.
But you have in your life right now,
if you haven't already done this,
is you have the chance to be heroic.
You have the ability right
now to make a heroic act.
They could kill you.
That's the thing,
these actions,
it's not always guaranteed that
because you do the right thing,
you're going to end up in a great place.
You might end up fucked.
You might end up,
you might end up temporarily and a
homeless or you might end up temporarily
jobless.
If there wasn't risk associated with it,
you would have already done it.
That's the point.
You know,
there wasn't risk associated with,
it wouldn't be worth anything.
You know,
if Mount Fucking,
uh,
you know,
if the Himalayas where you know,
a little green grass
covered hill in a park,
nobody takes pictures of them at the top.
Budding a flag into what is a danger.
Makes it heroic.
You know?
So sometimes you just have to fucking,
I sound like Tony Robbins.
Take the leap.
Kill the vampire in your life till
the vamp on you love is a brilliance.
Preach,
dude.
You,
you're dead right.
Anytime you fucking kill that vampire,
if you survive,
flowers will rain from heaven.
How's your bloom?
You can get better.
Everybody can get better.
We can all over their
eyes and move forward.
But you've got to be positive as fuck.
Don't be convinced that you
have anything figured out.
[inaudible].